whilst Malcolm Reynolds from Firefly
really just a sexist pig
let's discuss welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
so I came across an article and there's
a link in the description on marysue.com
um they basically say look they're a big
Firefly fan and they've watched it
recently they talked about how it was
successful and did it still stand up
today and then they went on to discuss
the failings of the show now one of the
points they made was that a premise of
the TV series was that the Chinese and
American cultures had sort of merged
together when we left Earth that was and
we created this new solar system that
actually the two most dominant cultures
on the planet had become the two most
dominant cultures in this new Society
they all spoke Chinese fluently it was
just a cheeky way to swear in Chinese as
far as I'm concerned but
um also we saw a lot of Chinese culture
writing symbols Etc but none of the main
characters actually were Chinese now
this is marysue.com points out that that
was a a problem and something that
really I can't argue with there probably
should have been a Chinese character I
wonder who would have been good
so
who's first I'm not really going to hold
it against just Sweden at this point I
don't think it was done on purpose
but she does point out the toxic
masculinity of Malcolm Reynolds as
another major problem Mercy is the mark
of a great man
oh I guess I'm just a good man
well I'm all right
[Music]
in the article it actually States Mao is
verbally abusive and unnecessarily cruel
to every woman he encounters now I have
to go back and I have to wonder if
that's actually true
it isn't now the one point they use is
his relationship with anara where he
calls her a and he calls her a
quite a few times I supported
unification
did you
well I don't suppose you're the only
that dude
the last time to call me now in
this article it suggested that he was
doing that because of Joss Whedon Joss
Whedon created the character and just
Whedon is toxically masculine it
actually states in the article that the
truth about Joss Whedon had come out and
really the whole show is targed with the
same brush
now Joss Whedon has been accused of
being a bully and people like Charisma
Carpenter from The Buffy series
basically said look he bullied me and he
was casually cruel on several occasions
apparently when she was pregnant at one
point he called a fat and things like
this
stories like this and articles like Mary
sue.com do focus on a lot of the women's
accusations against him they're
basically trying to link him in with the
me too movement and now it's not right
that anybody a boss talks to people like
Joss Sweden has spoken to a lot of the
actors it isn't he is a bully and he is
not a pleasant guy
but he's not a sexist I actually don't
believe he's a misogynist there were
stories about him having relationships
with younger actresses and things that
just means he's a man there's never been
accusations that I'm aware of that he
ever actually like sexually abused any
of these women just that he had
relationships with them
but what about the Malcolm Reynolds
character was he casually cruel to all
of the women in his life
was he sexually misogynistic against
Kaylee no he treated her like a little
sister was he towards Zoe no he treated
her like an equal
was he towards Christina Hendrick's
character whichever name she was picking
for that episode
no Mrs Reynolds was his wife kind of and
he treated her until you know she
poisoned him and knocked him unconscious
and then tried to have him killed with
respect at no point in any of these
other female characters have anything
but respect from Malcolm Reynolds
in the episode where they go and they
actually protect the brothel from the
evil guy who's trying to steal a baby
he did nothing but show respect he
actually felt very attracted to the
I don't know what you call a head
prostitute a Madam I don't really know
he put his life on the line to protect
those women and protect that baby
Malcolm Reynolds did have a very strong
sense of Honor but he was maybe a little
bit old-fashioned but kind of that was
the point because he was supposed to be
a cow Moyer
now yes he called inara a but he
also stood up and then got himself
killed when somebody else treated her
like he owned her I might not show
respect to your job but he didn't
respect you that's the difference
inara he doesn't even see you well I
guess death will solve the issue to
everyone's satisfaction inara actually
pointed out the contradiction to him and
he actually said look I might call you
that but he treats you like that and
that's the difference I treat you like a
person I just hate what you do for a
living and he hated what she did for a
living because he loved her
so yes he was old-fashioned yes he
didn't think whoring was a respectable
job even though in this Society it was
now in the article it says that look all
of this name calling Etc was supposed to
be flirty and romantic but it never came
across like that
but it did
he was flirty he was romantic and they
did bicker they make that point
repeatedly in the movie when inara
phones Malcolm and asks for help and
afterwards after the call Washington was
like is this a trap and he goes look did
you see me in anara argue no exactly
trap so that was their Dynamic she was
just as feisty as him she gave back just
as well as she got she never ran away
from the words and the names that
Malcolm Reynolds was calling her because
Joss Whedon wrote it that way
so was Malcolm Reynolds a toxic
misogynist no
it was a character that was supposed to
be a little old-fashioned but was also
supposed to be honorable and he did have
that sense of honor and about Joss
Whedon I just want to add the point that
James Masters that placed spike in Buffy
also talked about the bullying he said
at one point Joss Whedon had him up
against a wall and basically told him
that he was gonna and kill him James
Masters was accessing that interview so
what did you think about that what do
you think about Charisma card does this
and James Master said look the guy is a
perfectionist
he was getting a lot of crap from
Executives above people that were trying
to ruin his story as far as he was
concerned they kept changing his story
and he was just really really passionate
about the story he was trying to tell
yes the way he then expressed her
passion was wrong but he was not
misogynist he was not a sexist he was
not abusing anybody he was just
passionate about what he was doing now I
don't have any problem with Joss Whedon
I think the man needs anger management
skills I think he needs to calm the F
down but I don't think he deserves to be
lumped in with people like Harvey
Weinstein either and Malcolm Reynolds
was not a cruel unpleasant person he was
not written that way because Joss Whedon
is a cruel and unpleasant person the
marysue.com in this case has got it
completely wrong they've completely
misunderstood the character who actually
just stood up for what he believed in he
loved the crew of the siren T like his
family you can see that in several
episodes including
protecting inara but families sometimes
argue they bicker and they call each
other names to be honest if they didn't
it would be weird
and that's all this was it was a show
about a family on a Starship a
dysfunctional family maybe but still
family
but guys I'd love to know what you think
what do you think about the Malcolm
Reynolds character did you love him did
you hate him did you actually think at
times he was a misogynistic pig or
something else or toxically masculine
I don't know sure that means anymore but
was he get to the comments and tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification you know what to
do and also you can go to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack where most of
our new videos Premiere first and you
get to see them without the adverts as
always please stay safe and I'll see you
next time
foreign
[Music]